congratulations girl
thank you i'm not on a high right now i
think
i'm like i i perform you know so when i
got to go on stage and speak i get so
nervous
right like just like beyonce she's like
when she turns it on the stage is one
thing but to accept an award freaks me
out speaking of her why was it so
important for you to honor and pay
tribute to all of those legends and
icons that paved the way for you tonight
because they gave me the opportunity
like i said on stage to really be
the black girl that i am today and the
black artist and the woman that i've
really
you know evolved into yeah it's women
like that and it's them giving me
representation at an early age for me to
be able to you know when i was like four
or five years old to tell my mom and my
dad i want to be just like janet i want
to dance like sierra i want to be like
beyonce like what i'm seeing in the
television is who i want to be and they
really opened my mind to you know the
possibilities of who i had the
opportunity of becoming and for me that
means absolutely everything being here
tonight to honor shanti come on i was
not lying when i said that i used to be
in the back of my mom's car and we would
just be jamming
do you pinch yourself and you think
about like now these women are my peers
because i i got to be honest i see so
many parts of them in you wow thank you
thank you so much no that's like
that's an honor for you to even just say
and put me in the same sentence
you know you're shoulder to shoulder
with them now you know making a record
you're all on the spotify you all on the
apple music yes no god is great he
really really is you know
like i said for for black women
like myself it's not been an easy
journey
and so you know being a woman in a male
dominated field on top of being a black
woman but you know that's my power so
your super power and also i wanted to
thank sean bankhead i want to thank sean
bankhead i want to thank my my amazing
director tanu
and my team you know the list is really
endless you know for my a r team
who's worked with me tirelessly my
management team my parents my mom and my
dad and my grandma who had sacrificed so
much you know even when financially we
didn't have but they never let me know
and they continue to believe in the
dreams and aspirations that i said that
i wanted to do so i'm forever forever
grateful you're all pro-accepting
speeches that was perfect oh that was
part of the truth
i forgot so many people real quick
before i let you go what do you want to
tell the fans out there who and i know
you hear it and see it who are asking
where is the album where is the album
what do you want to tell them i want to
tell you
that
summer is going to be late get out yes
the summer's going to be lit so you
ready you're gearing up are you in
rehearsals are you doing
shoot we're doing everything we're doing
it all i'm ready to perform i miss
performing
you've been putting out the hit so i'm
excited to see the whole debut
[Music]
you